yeah hello and welcome to this video
round 11 of Tata Steel
2013 we nearing the Finish
Line just um including this round three
rounds to go I'm going to start with the
game kayin against zokolov and then
continue from there yeah kayin played
the
E4 as usual I think my sound is a t too
too
loud okay um play E4 as usual and zukov
sticks to his one E5 so always playing
one
E5 but he's mixing his systems against
the ru Lopez here he decides to go again
for
this this line which he has played
before with
um yeah zero success in this tournament
already losing to Carson and um I think
it was caruana um this arang variation
or Arch Angel
variation yeah I'm not sure if I think
if you lose two games with one line you
s simp simply switch to something else
he made a draw against arnard with
um here with
um with the schan Gambit or yanish
Gambit and he can play all kinds of
offbeat um lines in the ru and I know
why play this stuff again with with the
which you have lost two times um
admittedly he wasn't so bad in those
games but still all right D3
again as in those two uh games before
Bishop
C5 Knight C3 yeah this is
um not so common in the Roy Lopez very
often white plays Knight D2 but Knight
E2 has its points it can sometimes go to
D5 or can um switch to G3 via E2 this is
um an idea that sometimes is very
helpful and um also it um supports those
pins or makes those pins more
problematic we see what happens
D6 a A3 because black was threatening
Knight A5 grabing this bishop so um A3
is secures this um Square on A2 and now
black played H6 because Bishop G5 was
a bit of an annoying move Bishop G5 and
Knight D5 so this is why black played H6
yeah I think um around here certainly
black
um must be okay it's not um much
happening
really and
um Bishop C8 yeah we see that he's
regrouping this bishop which um as
mentioned more than once during this
tournament this Bishop's on B7 in the
rui against this Pawn
chain isn't so well
so regrouping it to this
diagonal Knight G3 Bishop
B6 yeah quite uh quite normal probably
intending to play with the c Pawn at a
later stage
C3 yeah and here
um maybe black um should consider I mean
it's not
um brilliant move but maybe you should
consider to actually take before white
plays D4 I think I would prefer that but
it's not clearcut that is better the
idea would be taking and then play
Bishop E6 trying to um exchange a couple
of pieces and relieve the
pressure um maybe um this is a better
better try to equalize if white doesn't
agree to the exchange on E6 play
something like this then um black can
even think about D
five and he's um yeah he's got more
space than in the game I'm not sure if
it is so great but look at the
game he um he didn't take and allowed
this E4 this D4 move and uh White now
has got a full Center and I'm I'm always
not so sure if this piece is really so
great on B6 black is still probably okay
but I would have preferred I think to
take um one important tactical Point
here is of course if black
would decide to grab on E
form then there's this
important trick which is very common in
the in the the Spanish
opening the defense of the E4 Pawn with
this nice
trick sometimes there's also this
move I think it's not so good here but
um yeah because of the the funny reply
um Rook
G4 and queen takes
C6 gets answered by Bishop B7 and black
actually gets a super dangerous attack
probably winning attack but Bishop D5 is
the problem okay he didn't take of
course but uh played Bishop
G4 trying to increase the pressure on
the
center and uh yeah white just moves the
queen away and now threatens to move the
Knight and then this bishop would be
very stupid on G4 so if black would
um play some nothing move not quite sure
what nothing move black could play
really let's say this I know it is
stupid but uh okay then white can
consider to to to move this Knight away
and then this bishop is um yeah in thin
air it can only Retreat to D7 at a later
stage
maybe black can play D5 here but okay
Rook A8 is a stupid move anyway but what
I'm talking about is this bishop it
needs to serve a purpose here and if
white has got time then he will move
this Knight away maybe not instantly but
then next couple of moves and then this
piece has no no um function on G4 this
is probably why it took on F3 but this
um leads to a strengthening of white
center and in fact after Knight
E7 and these moves um white has got a
really big
Center um black also couldn't really
prevent F4 if he would play Knight to
G6 controlling f4 on the F4 Square then
white has got Knight to F5 coming and
this is really something you don't want
to see this night on on this post and
very very
dangerous potentially it's also not easy
to uh get rid of if black would play
Knight E7 for example then white can
actually even even take
here just have a look
check and the next
sacrifice with a very strong attack for
white is probably winning even black
will take check get this
check and it's
over Queen G7 Knight
G6 this this simple move and black gets
gets
destroyed yeah so F4 wasn't uh wasn't um
to be avoided and now white has a strong
center it's
maybe still tactically feasible or but I
don't like it I mean I think I would uh
much prefer to be white in this position
yeah zov TR tries to get some play
against uh the king but uh it's really
not um
materializing yeah here curiously enough
um do the computer still likes Black's
position um I'm not
sure really I don't I don't like it at
all I must admit that um what what
Houdini for example wants to play is
this and um with an okay
evaluation let's still I I don't think
uh that this is so great I mean let's
say Rook G1 for example let's say let's
say Rook
G1 I didn't analyze it um so much
deeper but um isn't this looking
dangerous I don't I don't really uh
think that black can hope for much in
this
position yeah it's it's probably better
than the game but um
this exchanging on D4 and then C5 in the
game he took on F4 and look now
initiated this uh this um play but here
um white doesn't have this double pawns
anymore so I think this Pawn structure
is much better in
comparison and um yeah white uses his
Rooks Rook F2 and possibly Rook G1 or
Rook a to F1 according to
circumstances yeah C4 is a
move this basically admits that you're
you're on the wrong on the wrong track
here giving white um a completely um
solid Center that cannot be um in any
way
pressurized I think after this black is
almost
lost I don't think that you can save
this it's too much there's those things
on the king the G5 Knight
F5 and U the worst is that the pawns
start to roll if you look at the game
Bishop to d8 White
exchange and now
he got this bishop back into play and
this bishop is of course very strong
piece on B1 it covers E4 so that you can
play um the F4 advance and um
yeah and now the problem is F4 F5 and
black has absolutely no antidote against
this Rook Rook doesn't have either F4 F5
and in fact after F5 Queen G2 this is
hanging yeah this position there's the
threat Bishop to
D1 and um yeah trapping the queen you
cannot move move the Knight because of
Checkmate
exactly and so Bishop D1 is simply
deadly black has no way to to save the
material here if he would play let's say
Bishop to E7 Bishop D1 Knight H4 Rook F3
and then uh you have absolutely nothing
against um Rook to H3 under certain
right circumstances or just Rook to G3
and um this is simply too much on the G4
so pretty much like a oneway street
victory for for kayin and zov has lost
so many games in Rono I started to lost
count I think he made this draw against
vishy but then lost all his games a
terrible shape and um but I'm not sure
Ian why play this opening again with
which you have made
um no no points and he can play all
kinds of stuff at least surprising ying
a bit and not repeating the variation I
don't know I think if you're in bad
shape you simply have um yeah have a
hard time making good decisions even
before the game all right so the next
game um is uh let's let's pick who you
fought against Anan so the
tournament um
Underdog from China against I readjust
the ball a little bit from China against
the the world champion uh but you found
really uh I think that you really got
into this tournament um quite nicely by
now she lost uh quite a couple of games
at the beginning and not in too great uh
yeah in too great fashion I mean
sometimes making really weird decisions
but she won two games by now and um even
has some some
positive um ELO result won a couple of
points so I guess she can be
satisfied up to now okay let's see E4
she always plays E4 and VI goes for the
n
off and Bishop G5 which is the sharpest
move and maybe the main line again after
a couple of years really a long time
where this move was out of fashion but
it is back and Knight bd7 yeah this
pretty much signals that Anand wants to
win this game and at a very early stage
the night of itself
um while he plays this in all kinds of
situations but um E6 for example
F4 Queen to B6 which is what he usually
does play um um the pro problem with
this line is that there's a ton of
um lines very forcing lines in which
black can only draw the game game white
um in a way just needs to learn and know
one specific line or two specific lines
and then can very very reliably draw or
black must risk too much so this is his
usual choice if a draw isn't too too
terrible but here Knight bd7 um
instantly avoids any direct
draws Queen E2 yeah this is um
pretty unusual setup with uh the queen
blocking the bishop it's far more um
common place to play
F4 directly F4 and queen F3 but Queen E2
has um its points the idea is let's um
let's have a look what happens like
pledge
A6 and G6 interesting setup and quite
unusual looking E6 would be uh would be
normal
but okay why not try to Fe and Shadow
this and one point of the queen on E2 is
that it is opposite Black's King we see
um what might happen F4 yeah after F4
here white um of course intends to play
E5 uh so if black would um Play Bishop
G7 for example then you need to reckon
with D5
already something like
this probably this was too early here
with E5 hanging but uh it's it's quite
dangerous the Knight is offside and I
don't think that black really wants to
uh wants to go into this he played Just
E5 directly putting a foothold in the
center but it's a strange mix of those
moves and then E5 I must admit okay why
took and now castled long and this is um
a typical point point of this queen E2
move if black would grab the Knight now
then E5 is uh yeah deadly already I
guess threatening e takes F6 with um
yeah devastating attack along the eal
black uh yeah simply has no good move
here cannot take the Knight and V she
just played Bishop E7 so this G6 move
was uh now looks a bit um a bit super
fluous but of course it prevents Knight
to F5 in this concrete position okay
White NOW needs to react to the Knight
hanging Queen C7 and queen C4 which is
uh interesting and probably um a good
decision black now needs to retreat the
the queen played Queen to B8 um I think
black couldn't really take here this
gives white too much development you can
also look at Rook F1 later and uh some
play along the F I'm not sure I think
this um might lead might lead to some
white Advantage simply a matter of
development Advantage from a structure
point of view black isn't too um too bad
but don't have uh the pieces coordinated
yet and you still have the king in the
center which means the Rooks are not
connected so um this was was the the
best probably
Knight to D5
B5 Queen
C6 and Knight takes
D5 yeah a couple of um relatively
forcing moves also Queen B7 was uh
probably forcing or forced because now
it is pinned here the the Knight and
white threatens move like moves like
Knight Rook takes E5
and um this is very hairy for black if
he would take now white simply
recaptures and also has this kind of
ideas now Knight takes
G6 amongst others it's just Rook takes
E5 um is a problem if black screen would
move Rook takes E5 wins and what should
black play so what he did is perfectly
all right Queen
B7 Queen C3
retreating and F6 which looks really
ugly at first s but if you look at it
um with um yeah with with some time and
uh then you will appreciate that this is
not really a weakness it looks very weak
this G6 pawn and the whole kind of
structure looks uh looks weak here
advancing uh pawns just one square on
the on the neighboring
um um neighboring um squares is often
often strange like A3 B3 C3 it's always
quite Airy for the king it's um bit
insecure but it doesn't really matter in
this position because black gets a Time
on on the rook and um gets a proper
setup Bishop
F2 and uh Knight B6 this was the idea
gaining a Tempo on The Rook Rook
retreated and Knight A4 attacking
um the
queen here um the most natural looking
move is probably Bishop to E6 but um
then Knight takes E5 is a move that
might irritate
black something like
this and white
um yeah it looks dangerous for black I
didn't really would like to uh play that
yeah black played Knight A4 first
attacking the
queen and queen C6 which prepares Bishop
to E6 and forces White's next move
Bishop E6 um would be really really
problematic for for white so um she
needed to play Queen D5 basically
getting rid of the queen but this now
leads to um a fine position for black
and and um I'm not 100% sure where white
should
um
improve the play before because it is
relatively
clear that uh this position is
um
really better for black it's not quite
clear how much at least it's not clear
to me after a brief analysis but it's
clear that black is the one um who's um
better simply
because one fact this Pawn on D5 it is a
pass pawn and um very often pass Pawn
means you have got an advantage but here
the problem is that this Pawn is largely
U yeah unsupported this it's not covered
by U by another Pawn if have C4 for
example would cover the pawn and it can
be attacked in the long run if you look
at um the game continuations you played
Bishop G3 I thought that Bishop takes C5
which was more natural but okay maybe it
was better to take on C5 I'm not quite
sure what this bishop is doing okay
Anand Knight B6 attacking this pawn and
uh preventing C4 this is important that
D doesn't get to cover this
Pawn she played Bishop to D3 attacking
G6 and now a strong reply Bishop to F4
F5 it is absolutely not important that
this pawns might get doubled on on the F
this is even an advantage because he
controls so many important Central
squares look at this those pawns
here they
control the whole Center and now we see
the the isolated state of this Pawn just
Rook to d8 and it's
gone or long castles it's the same the
D5 Pawn is
gone
check yeah so um let's take stock black
um has an extra Pawn a nicely
centralized Knight and uh good influence
on the center okay this is potentially a
bit shaky those pawns but um it's not
apparent how white should win one of
them she can attack um The Pawn on F5
but um hard to win it
check yeah regrouping attacking also
B2 and now black grabbed on G3 um if um
black would take on
B2 then um Rook D6 gives white some
counter play attacking those two pawns I
think it's um a bit unnecessary to to
give wi this
activity he took
here and uh yeah it's a little little
kind of trap take on G3 and now
white played
B3 and this allows a really nice really
nice trick which um finally or finally
which really should win for black and
this is a move Rook
d8 simply ignoring this this Knight is
hanging the problem is if white would
take the Knight then this exchange and
taking on H2 gives black a new
queen and the same um applies of course
if white would take first then take here
and it's still a new Queen and uh this
means um because look at the
position
I think I somewh
overrode the the moves
here bear with me I need
to reload
this
check
check yeah rook d8 and uh this means um
that the rookie exchange is almost
unavoidable as there's no other move if
white would let's say move away The Rook
the only way to avoid the exchange then
Black's got Rook D2 and Rook H2 coming
and winning
easily okay so you need to exchange no
big Choice and then retake on on
G3 Knight D6 yeah and now we got um a
pure night end game which um should be
um totally winning for black
simply um because he's got an extra pawn
and um it's very rare that um Knight
endings with extra pawns are not winning
it is um a bit comparable to pawn
endings in fact this is V Wick's famous
rule that Knight end games are almost
identical to in evaluation to to um to
King and porn end games so um he gave
the advice to just think of the position
without the knights and and evaluate
this position and if you think that uh
the exra pawn or the position whatever
is winning for one side then it's very
likely that this is also the case with
the knights and in this case
here are both end games um are winning
um let's see what
happened yeah this is fine and now black
of course needs to activate the king
which she uh which she did of
course B4 yeah and now we come to
um the important point of this game um
look at the clock Arland it's got a
huge time Advantage who you find always
was um in time trouble in this game even
early Le on she had used much more time
and now arnan played Knight to
F5 spending 30 seconds according to this
clock and in fact Knight F5 is a really
big mistake that uh spoils the whole
Advantage black could win rather easily
and I think he would win his win it also
in his in his sleep yeah just needs to
uh sit sit sit tight think two minutes
or something and then uh then play it
correctly so what what's winning is
simple move like
H5 A4 King D5 just continuing to to
strengthen the position without
exchanging the Knights of course as I
just explained very often
the the king and pawn hand game with the
extra Pawn is winning almost always but
almost is uh not good enough in chess
you need to um look at each position
position um um on its own and this for
this here is is completely over because
white cannot even move um something
decent here move the Knight then Knight
F5 picks up the G3 pawn and you're in in
zuk Swang here King E3 King C4 is
easy as is King C3 Knight E4 picking up
the pawn so H5 was super simple win and
I guess he
simply did some kind of silly
miscalculation um in the king and pawn
end game
because of course black is attacking G3
it's so
white if she would move the Knight then
G3 is just just gone and um I'm not
quite sure what miscalculation it was
but look what happens Knight F5 takes
takes A4 and uh this is of course the
counter
play if black now would um simply ignore
all this then of course you would simply
lose because white is quicker so you
cannot just go here and take this spawn
then simply B5 is uh is winning oh it's
not
winning oh I need to oh this is curious
because of the counter play of course
yeah white white needs to uh move the
king first I'm sorry I I I I analyzed
this before and I made some some notes
of course and um I I got confused the
problem is if you play B5 then black
can go here this is important and then
gain a Tempo with his check so you um
can actually draw this as
black and what white needs to do is
after King G4 needs to first take away
the square and stop the E Pawn and then
you can let uh let your own Pawn um go
forward so in the
game he played King to E6 attending to
to the
pawn then G4 important stopping two
pawns and now we already see what what
the problem is in this kind of
position the king and this Pawn really
uh they do a good job of stopping these
pawns it's not easy for black to advance
King D5 and just King C3 and how do you
make progress now it's really curious
black would U Advance again then white
can play B5 and of
course something like this might
happen and now black um doesn't really
have have anything else than
E4 and
this will end in a total
draw and why this why is quick
enough so it's a Curious Case of um a
king at Pawn end game with an extra Pawn
that is not winning and this is due to
White's counterplay and Black's
relatively
um unlucky position of this Pawn against
those two pawns so it's basically that
this single Pawn on G4 stops two black
pawns and so the exra pawn isn't felt so
much the problem was really that in this
position here black needed to go back
and allow G4 and uh this is why H5 is uh
is
essential before before you play the
Knight
exchange all right so in the
game I had it
almost King E4 King C2 yeah this is also
a
draw and uh we simply have a couple of
more moves and now a simply a simple um
a line that is similar to the one I
shown and now V she offered the
draw yeah he must have been certainly
very disappointed to just spoil this
this game with the really um easy
blunder for his class very easy blunder
Knight F5 he simply played too quickly
it it happens if you think yeah if you I
know this too well I mean it happens to
me also you think okay why why isn't the
opponent not resigning isn't this
completely winning and then you play a
quick move and uh really rather would
like to go home or have whatever uh have
the game finished and um the opponent
simply doesn't resign but even can draw
after you make um um a silly move that
was played too quickly so a draw
for the Chinese player here very nice
drawing the world champion but of course
very lucky I mean
this happens really rarely to to Arnold
that he spored such a a big winning
Advantage okay so um the next game let's
have a look at
um um ah let's let's pick um let's pick
let's pick Nakamura against
aronian at least then I don't forget
nakamura's
game as it happened to me before okay
Nakamura playing D4 and we got a
slav
and uh yeah aronian is playing this
um A6 line which uh was employed by the
world champion in the match um against
Gant last year and Gant didn't really um
get much um against this move he won one
game gont um and this was with the C5
and this is also what Nakamura is
playing here
now white B2 D6 S Knight
A4 and uh this has been played
before it doesn't look too attractive
for black at first but the idea is to to
go C5 next move and then black would
free his position quite a bit Nakamura
now played Queen to C2 in fact the main
move in this position um by
far is Knight E5 after um which black
normally goes C5 and we get this kind of
um end
game where white has got the bishop pair
but Black's got quite good um good piece
placement Knight to E4 is a a
possibility and uh he's got some play
along the B and C far black is um a bit
better developed in a way for the bishop
pair but Nakamura played Queen to C2
back and I'm not sure if this is really
an
improvement this uh
whole line doesn't seem
to be uh too great for white I mean not
that it is bad but it doesn't seem to
promise much really okay aronian prar
C5 Rook C1 preventing this and Rook B8
yeah and now um
Nakamura played an interesting move
which surprised me he just gave away the
the B2
Pawn if white would uh cover the pawn
let's say with B3
to analyze the concrete line then black
has got the possibility of
playing Bishop A3 attacking the rook and
if it moves away then black gets in this
important move c65 if black manages to
play C5 without getting uh punished then
um he certainly is all
right so um Nakamura sacrificed pawn and
canceled and I think it is probably a
good enough to um yeah to have enough
counterplay um to to equalize but it's
not a pawn sacrifice that really
um threatens to refute black set up
Arona played Bishop D6 he also could
have considered to just take on C2 maybe
it was was Stronger but um it's not a
huge difference so we've got the
exchange now and black playing C5 as
mentioned this is the key advance that
you need to get in and uh this basically
forces what what's happening next Black
is threatening to uh to take or to play
C4 uh C4 is of course the much bigger
issue
he took on
D7 takes and again this C4 move and
Nakamura now took on A6 which is really
a bit of a risky move um he also could
have played just taking on C5 Knight
takes and Bishop
Retreats and um okay it's uh it's a pawn
down but um there's some activity he got
chances to put a bit of pressure against
um the C5 Knight and if it should move
then A6 is um
hanging yeah it's um not too great for
white the thing is in the
game he
took getting the material back the pawn
back but black got this Pawn
now and um this this is a bit of an
offside piece okay you see that um with
this setup here with
the possibility to get it to B5 um white
stabilizes this piece but I think black
is the one to to try in this position
with this pass Pawn uh E4 the the move
here is an interesting attempt to
activate this bishop it was a really a
bad piece and now we've got Bishop F4
coming of course black shouldn't take on
on e4 as this would would really help
white the protected pass Pawn now is
way so Knight to E8 which is interesting
he wants to go to
D6 and U therefore still keeping some
pressure on e4 but also protecting the
C4 Pawn once again and preventing knight
uh Bishop uh to B5 or not preventing it
but then having the opportunity to
capture it
yeah preparing Knight to
D6 and here we
go yeah Rook B1 logical attacking this
piece and Bishop to
A5 yeah this bishop might one day be
used on B6 to put pressure on
D4 yeah here King
F1
F6 yeah a good streng strengthening move
controlling
E5
so both sides improve the position a
bit C3 yeah and now it U it gets really
really critical
C3 just um Sharp opens up the position
um a lot and then now white needs to
play precise moves and in fact he um
fails instantly here what he should do
and must do really um is um Rook to
B3 the the point is it's simply the only
move that you can play he played in the
game um Rook to E2 and this is meant by
a very strong response if you um have
some time on your hands then um stop the
video and look for yourself treat it as
a puzzle what should black play
now I'll be quiet for a couple of
seconds so you have time to stop
it yeah black has very strong move here
with
E5 and the point is yeah white um really
doesn't have much Choice he he took on
E5 um if white would Retreat the bishop
the only alternative then black simply
can take
here and one one a pawn now with the C3
Pawn being on the board and this um
is just a terrible position probably
it's straight it's straight lost for
white
so um he he took in the game and now
Black's idea Knight takes
B5 a takes B5 and D4 this was the
important point that you needed uh that
you needed to see
beforehand with h with
E5 Rook
D1 yeah and here um a quite quite
curious moment but uh not first he took
this is all right and this has got um
Rook B1 as an idea so if white would
take here this what I'm talking about
then there's Rook B1 and um simply no
move if um white would exchange
check then those pawns uh really decide
very very
quickly the idea simply of E5 was
to fight uh for
some yeah so just um get those two um
connected pawns on the
road so what I'm talking about is Rook
C2 it was it was necessary simply to
have Rook C1 on um on Rook B1 um and
here it's it's an interesting moment um
aronian um
very surprisingly played D3 and
quickly um I was really U surprised by
this because I'm not 100% sure that this
move really wins um
tactically and uh he had a very simple
alternative of course just taking on E5
which um leaves black with an extra Pawn
but we've got those pawns and uh White
needs to um Locate
the pawns with King and and Rooks so
very bad blockading
pieces um I mean this should should be
technically winning in some
way it's uh it's not like a quick win
but uh I think he probably miscalculated
with D3
somehow look at what happened he played
D3 and this looks really um weird to
just uh throw in the the pawn white
takes check
check and now uh in fact Nakamura played
the bishop to C1 he had 11 minutes left
but um the only move that was still
playable um was King
F2 and after this um it's not super
clearcut that black is is really winning
black has a distinct Advantage but um
it's not so clear if uh if it is an easy
win let's say Rook B
two Rook e Rook
E2 and um how exactly do you do you make
progress
now if if black would would play
C2 the problem is there's no real threat
I still control this square and after
Bishop
C1 and something like this white still
hangs
on it's not clear that black is winning
King F2 um was maybe underestimated by
aronian but it was the case of
neutral oversights as Nakamura played
Bishop to C1 and this in fact isn't uh
playable at all because of this very
strong move and uh what should white do
now cannot take on B2 and you cannot
really do something else than what he
did in the game just this is uh
sacrificing the exchange but the problem
is after this it's not just an exchange
this pin is uh the big issue this bishop
is almost lost here um black had more
than one good move he played Rook D2 the
alternative was um the funny move Rook
to A1 with this idea and it's both
winning Rook
D2 is also winning threatening Rook D1
check why
check get those
checks here yeah and now uh the problem
is this Rook D1 idea white really has no
way to um to defend if he would play
King E1 attacking this you can simply
take and uh it's
um at the end this bishop is
falling those Rooks are just too
terrible so this is why white um gave up
the bishop and then grabbed the H Pawn
and uh okay it's not um a difficult
technical task Rook D7 and Rook to C7
this is precise getting rid of The Rook
or threatening to get rid of The Rook
with Rook H7 and uh this is why Nakamura
played rook h8 and now
check did go away with Rook but now of
course there's simply this Pawn
falling and here um Nakamura finally
resigned yeah certainly a disappointing
finish for him but um he really
overlooked um two two things this E5
move Landing white into into really big
trouble and then um Bishop C1 gave the
game away for a second time with King F2
you could still uh fight
it's not much fun but you can you can
fight on and maybe draw but um Bishop C1
was losing instantly after Rook A2 B2 so
um yeah good win for aronian here an
important win and he's
um on track um following Caren who of
course uh is very far away but uh still
a respectable tournament for aronian who
also wasn't in so great shape lately so
um a good Resort
okay so next game let's pick um giri
against
kowana and uh this is really a game of
two players uh who rather for forgot
this tournament I
think caruana one of the yeah maybe
despite cards and successes the player
of uh the last year really made the huge
strides
forward um being the co-winner of this
uh this how it is called the Masters
final in B and
um yeah in sa Paulo and
BAU and getting his rating to close to
2,800 okay um plays giri here who didn't
win a game yet at this
tournament so
um let's see what happens between
between those two uh tail Enders um yeah
Carana plays the so-called triangle
setup with C6 and E6 and this invites a
couple of very sharp lines and in fact
giri um doesn't mind to allow this
so-call notab variation named after
Dutch player Daniel notab
Boom the idea of this line actually is
have a look um if white would now if
white would this is wrong I learned this
uh
earlier this week but it's very hard to
correct if you used to do this um okay
if white plays E3 now then black
responds B5 and um really covers this
pawn and this leads to very sharp play
for example Bishop D2 A5
even takes takes takes takes E3 Bishop
B7 takes
I'm just putting U the main line on the
board and um we have a very unbalanced
situation where White's Center is
fighting against two outside pass pawns
by black it's a very very enterprising
opening for both sides actually and very
interesting to play I played this a
couple of times with black when I was uh
younger and still
being able to calculate some
lines okay return to the game um giri in
fact um didn't go for one of the main
lines he just played G3 which is really
a rare move but um it's a it's pretty um
if you look at this it's it's very
similar to uh to some Cataline setups
where black had grabbed the pawn and
played Bishop to B4 and it's certainly a
playable playable setup
Knight F6 Bishop
G2 Knight D7 I'm I'm
not completely sure about this move I
didn't uh look this up if there's some
theory about all this but um my instant
reaction at least would be to to play C5
or play castles and C5 if possible
trying to um to develop the Knight to C6
if um if possible um but okay Knight D7
is probably not a mistake would be
strange really if this would be a
mistake but um I think if you look at um
the continuation Queen C2 Queen A5 maybe
around here there's uh the spot where
you need to um improve because black
really really quickly um is in in huge
trouble um Knight to
A2 yeah the bishop Retreats he don't
want to give this bishop bishop and now
white grab C4 and uh okay of course what
black is doing now is um is wrong and
leads to uh big trouble but the whole
setup here looks very uh passive to me
this uh thing against white probably
ready to occupy much more space um and
the problem is it's not setup itself but
you cannot really go E5 or maybe you
could could play E5 here yeah this could
be an improvement but you need to do
something here because you're playing
without your C8 Bishop while white has
got all all the pluses what he did um
was really too cheeky he played Knight
to
B6 and uh this this now gets black into
huge trouble Queen C2 and okay here was
the last absolutely last point where you
could uh could um trying to improve um
maybe Queen F5 is a is still still a
move just attacking the queen so let say
and white white would take this isn't
too great black has got good central
control probably white would move the
queen again Queen B3 um is just answered
by this
doesn't help but you can just um go back
and introduce this return and E4 and
here black maybe can play E5 at some
point and this is at least better than
the game in the game he grabbed on A4
and this uh leads
to really
disaster um yeah here giri actually
could have played better even he played
Knight E5 which leads to a huge position
for for white but um he had the
alternative E4 and this seems to be even
stronger the the idea is um that uh well
E5 of course not exactly um very
sophisticated but this not even not only
threatens a fork but also takes away
important squares for the queen and the
queen can easily um get trapped here
let's say black plays Bishop C7 which is
relatively uh the best
move um Knight
G5 threatening
E5 and for example if black would play
H6 now kicking the Knight then there's
uh this and now you see that this queen
has um really really little space to
move something like this could be the
consequence and this is just uh just
gone for black you lose um the queen get
mated
or um it's uh it's really over
so um E4 was really really strong so H6
not working here we can look at this
defensive try also giving the queen a
square then E5
H6 B4 Queen
B6 something like this just one line and
now the threat is
d45 and black has got a terrible
position he will simply get uh torn
apart probably on the king side white is
still a pawn down but look at this
position yeah really a a big big um
attack for
white what um gir played the Knight E5
also is is very strong it's just not
that forceful in
comparison Knight B2
D7 it's very hard to um give black some
advice if you would take you can can
take a look at this then white has this
strong reply he doesn't uh recapture on
E5 but place this first and
um this is quite similar to a line that
we looked at
before again this uh is over for black
where do you go
now it leads to terrible positions like
this just for example
now attacking the rook and if it moves
then a move like this wins uh the
exchange or other forms of material
black cannot U Move anything even he's
got this silly Queen on ag3
stranded
terrible okay so he cannot take and this
is why he went Knight B to D7 Knight
C4
so um giri played it simple but it's
it's very strong you've got um this huge
Bishop you've got this potential idea
not at the moment it is covered but it
is in the position Bishop F4 E4 E5 so
white has a huge compensation
really
E5 Knight C3 what white likes to do is
of course get this move in
black
took winning a Tempo
here and E3 so idea is open up the
center and um what should black do
simply e takes D4 as a threat and he
decided to uh give away um the pawn with
with
D3 yeah white can simply take
it
Retreat Knight D5 and uh yeah this more
and more is approaching to to a
nightmare for Karana swi has got
fantastic
pieces he decided to exchange but it's
really too late this position is already
winning for white so it's simply too
much Rook takes D5 is uh in fact a good
and uh an interesting decision Bishop
takes D5 looks looks like the normal
recapture but this is just stronger The
Rook um actually has the idea to swing
over to the king
side B6 and here um Bishop B2 is strong
just getting this bishop back into
play and uh having a look at the G7
Pawn
A5 and um yeah of course here there's
more than one way to win I think giri
played a very e static move with the
Rook A4 and in fact um you could also
instantly win here with Rook to
H5 the the point being and this is maybe
what he didn't see but it's of course a
bit of a computer is line um first this
threatens Checkmate if um black would
try to cover it in this fashion then
Bishop D5 wins and there's no way to
defend against Queen G6 or Rook takes
H6 utilizing this spin so let's say
Bishop to B7 just to put something on
the board then that this move
threatening Checkmate if takes then this
is made in one
even Rook H5 probably he was put off by
G6 but in fact white has a very
attractive looking uh move against this
and this is the very um visually
pleasing move
Queen to F5 a self Fork I don't see this
too
often but it's winning what can you do
um it's simply Rook takes H7 the threat
and uh you cannot take one of the pieces
Checkmate one mate and of course this is
Checkmate the twin solution so the same
so black cannot take one of those pieces
and Rook takes H7 is simply deadly he
cannot prevent it so some queen move
here and uh and
resigns just
made so this was uh wasn't spotted by
giri but okay it it doesn't matter
really he played Rook A4 and this is
also very um aesthetic using all pieces
in the attack and Swinging this Rook
over over
also so Rook E8 played Rook G5
threatening on
G7 only move Bishop D5 threatening Rook
takes G6 so if black would play
something like this then Rook takes G6
is the
winner
check checkmate like
this of course um just just to mention
it it is uh absolutely
uh not advisable to take the exchange
yeah of course you need to Checkmate
here if you would uh take it just
uh just to put it on the board um it's
not completely winning I mean white
doesn't have any
sacrifices he's probably uh better but
um just attacking and and mating black
is the the thing to do here not grabbing
um Small Change in the corner so to say
so this is just better threatening uh
this
sacrifice King to
f8 and now Rook F4 and uh this is really
a picture of domination all pieces
attacking the king and uh kwana resigned
there's no no defense at all um for
example let's say Rook E7 then white can
can take here
even
and um this is uh this is
over just this threat and no defense
black
would if black plays not if black would
play I'm sorry I Lear it at one one day
check then there's this
check and Rook
F7 no defense at
all yeah as mentioned after Rook F4
Karana resigned and um he's really
having a bad tournament he lost to um
Nakamura the round before and now got
got this spanking really a terrible
loss but nice for giri he won his first
game and I think it's really important
to at least have a win in the back even
if you don't have uh a great tournament
you really should uh should have won a
game
all right so um I'm noticing that this
will be a very long video but uh well
who cares um next game uh W how against
Cen
um wait where is it here wow against
card so Magnus on Roll let's see what
he's doing against um the Chinese number
one
wow playing E4 he's mixing his moves and
Carson also with um is it a surprise
well he played E5 mostly in this
tournament but he plays all kinds of
openings so hard to tell what's really a
surprise
um okay Bishop to
B5 which um avoids all kinds of open
Sicilians Carlson um hard to predict
what he would have played after D4 maybe
the shikov not
sure yeah Bishop B5 is a good
alternative for white players looking to
um have a
less less sharp game a more strategic
kind of battle um and less
theoretical play than in the open cilian
black has um some choices E6 G6
D6 so all these small moves are good he
played E6
Knight E7 which is one of the main
setups Rook E1 and uh yeah here black
can also think U of playing A6 which um
would force White's Bishop either back
or Force The Exchange which would I
think
um be okay for black probably to have
this Knight recapture uh of course one
issue is um the development white is
much better developed black spent lots
of time on moving the the knights and A6
A6 and so on um it's an alternative
though A6 white um mostly goes back to
F1 though and uh later occupies the
center car played Knight G6 though C3
and of course one feature of the Roso
limo variation as it is called is uh the
later idea to occupy with the ideal
Center and black um cards immediately
played to D5 himself um and I'm not sure
I I didn't have the time to really study
the opening in detail but the the way
this uh this is unfolding um is really a
bit problematic for black Bishop E7 no
okay you temporarily offers a pawn which
white didn't take um understandably so
look at
this just put it on the board something
like this um is probably quite okay for
black he's now better developed even
just needs to Castle and has Bishop C6
winning another Tempo and he's got two
Bishops so nice position grabbing the
pawn is uh really bad for white so uh D4
is what he
played continuing to develop and now
castles
and white exchange on
D5 yeah black probably needs to take
with the queen if you uh take here then
um yeah maybe I don't know is this
good it looks tricky for
black he probably needs to take with the
queen I mean he did this he played this
move and uh but if you look at this now
that's Knight um E4
coming here C and played um Queen all
the way First bishop B7 I'm sorry Queen
C4 threatening Knight to
B6 and this was um answered by Queen to
d8 and uh around here I think it um it's
clear that something has went um
something went wrong for black he's in
uh in some trouble now on Wang how
took and uh now played Knight to
D4 here um a very interesting
alternative was to um to go Knight F2 E5
attacking
E5 attacking um the the pawn on C6 from
E5 a possible continuation would be
would be something like this if um black
sacrifices the pawn here
this uh even would
be fine for black attacking here
intending the
pin but white can go
here to play something like this which
um looks um
much yeah is it much more comfortable
for white it looks good for white this
is a weak pawn and Black's got the two
Bishops but they're not doing so much
it's it's um it's hard to decide um
compared to the game what is
better if you look at the game Knight D4
C5
check got uh this maybe um here Queen
takes E7 was
better because here black guy doesn't
really have a choice he basically needs
to exchange otherwise the pawn is gone
instantly and this is really an
comfortable end
game it's the kind of end game where you
can easily imagine with Magnus being on
the white side to see some 100 move
torture Bishop A6 controlling this uh
Square in front of the weak pawn and
this is of course the issue this Pawn is
really weak and uh this Knight on A5
it's on the rim but it's a really
annoying piece always um with ideas like
Knight C6 on Knight B3 attacking this
pawn and it's not easily um driven away
from
A5 Bishop
G5 Rook yeah probably black needs to do
this if you you kind of don't don't
really have a good Square something like
this um probably gets answered by
C4 and the Knight needs to go to squares
where it doesn't really want to go so
Rook
d8 and Rook D1 is uh
logical with those kind of ideas and now
Magnus played H6 even
forcing this this exchange okay why
took and played
C4 C4 I think was designed to prevent
Bishop to B5 so if white would have
taken this U chance to attack the the
bishop then probably Bishop to be 5 was
a good response even um dropping this
back to E8 if
necessary so um oops he played
C4 um preventing this and um yeah what
is uh Black's problem here still this
Pawn in lots of cases um it can be a
problem that this Pawn is simply
attacked at some point and it cannot be
defended by the bishop as it's of course
simply uh on the other color
so um this is a problem for black this
weakness it's quite curious how this uh
unfolded now King f8 Rook to
D6 normal I think attacking
this black needed to play this no uh no
choice at
all e to D1 all
normal King to E8 black uh needs to Ed
the king also to defend the position and
here um wanghao really played a very
surprising move and um he probably has
um had miscalculated
something um but uh still it's hard for
me to understand this um because you had
um simple continuation that really um
obviously keep your advantage and um
maybe increase it
um I think a normal move um not the only
one but a normal move would have been
something like F3
to allow the the king to participate and
then you um have various ideas you can
play a very slowly you can regroup this
Knight it um can be used on D3 for
example at some stage or um regroup to
A4 where it attacks a the pawn just
various ideas to to um to play and the
other idea which is very direct but
probably not bad is to um continue with
A3 and B4 which um simply tries to get a
pass Pawn on the queen side and while
white is doing all this it's really
unclear what what Black's play is he
doesn't really have
much this looks very very tricky for
black and not at all easy to
defend maybe possible but very um very
thankless
task what the what Wang how played
actually was Knight to C6 and
uh yeah the only reason why you would
play this move is uh that it wins
instantly but in fact it doesn't because
you don't want to exchange uh really
your advantage the Knight is simply the
better piece in this static structure
and uh now Carin
takes and gets counter playay
immediately on the B
Pawn and here we go
A5 very very active and
uh and this uh in fact is securing the
draw immediately and I'm not quite sure
what one how calculate here because well
it is obvious Knight C6 black Hecks it
off plays Rook B7 what else A5 for draw
and uh maybe maybe he his mindset was so
focused on uh playing a draw that he
wasn't looking for more but um hard to
hard to understand maybe it's
um an idea to um to to watch this those
short interviews that they do after the
game I didn't manage that yet um to to
learn what what really was uh the
idea that that he had with Knight C6 all
right
A5 A4 counter play is on the way and um
black easily exchanges pawns here and
wins one Pawn back at the end just
needing to be precise one more move
White NOW played H4 um and there's
really no U big alternative if white
would take um then simply Rook takes and
you don't
um have any way to defend both
weaknesses black will win one Pawn back
and be absolutely
fine when the game H4
takes takes and this is the last move
that you need to see at black if you
would take here then Rook to C7 is uh
really a
problem and white still has ideas and
maybe even this is um is playable but
it's completely unnecessary just this
solves all problems this move is um a
gonner anyway and white plays some move
let's say here you just take then and if
white would now try to if White NOW
occupies the seventh rank then you can
drop back and
um it's simply it's simply nothing to
play
for so um slightly Lucky Draw maybe for
for Carlson here
Who Um probably made some mistake in in
the opening somewhere here I don't know
this this loses lots of Time Queen
D5 yeah capture on C5 then back and
queen back and um this wasn't ideal
obviously and leading to to some trouble
he also had if you look at the time he
was much down on the clock so a bit of
an opening
accident Okay so I managed quite a
couple of games but uh we're not uh we
don't have have them all Lami against
har
Krishna okay I need to do this uh more
quickly this video is already very
long okay a queen's Indian
here and lamia plays the petan variation
we had seen this before in this
tournament by arnard against kakin um
and uh here different line with taking
on
D5 white occupies a nice Center which is
attacked immediately with
C5 so um this
um line in the Queen's Indian Pion
is slightly um similar to to the
grunfeld if you look at the
structure the only difference is that
black um usually doesn't fianchetto in
fact here in the game we got the
fianchetto very often Bishop E7 has just
played but here it looks very uh
gromford
like A4 castles yeah and here um in this
position in fact Lami played
um A5 of course the The Logical followup
after you played A4 but this initiates
um the upcoming Pawns structure and um
to be honest I have a hard time
understanding what is going on in this
Pawn structure he just took
it and uh this means that black has got
a a pass Pawn on the aou white of course
gets this Pawn back we can go forward a
couple of
moves yeah black um gave away the pawn
wasn't possible to hold it anyway and uh
now
A5 and uh so black has got this pass
pawn and um still what is this position
is it is it equal I'm really not sure
how to how to assess this um I actually
think that maybe black is rather
comfortable here because I don't really
see what white is doing in this position
black has The Simple Plan of pushing
this pawn and uh White doesn't really
have a clear um way to uh initiate
counterplay here against the pawn um
simply because you've got this piece
here the queen on the queen side and um
you really uh
would like to have this piece on some
some other Square maybe on the kingside
trying to support a kingside attack or
somewhere um to support the Breakthrough
in the center white really doesn't have
much to play
for while black can push the
pawn and
um I'm not sure what what's clear is
just a couple of moves later white is in
in real danger and um I I don't see how
how he could improve he cannot really
play D5 E5 also um it's not really
possible and how do you make any
progress this white it's really
tricky yeah black um doesn't mind to
exchange Rooks he's got the a pawn got
all these
exchanges and um it's clear that um of
course black is is better now he won the
tempo here on the bishop this is hanging
and you've got the a pawn so something
went wrong before for white the question
though is uh how bad is this
really um white is certainly um
uncomfortable but are you really in big
trouble okay he played Bishop C2 if um
black would now decide to take on e4 you
can
take and get this back with um no big
problems for
white still comfortable for black but of
course Black's got something better in
the game you played Knight B6 and um
certainly a good move um
alternatives one is Bishop to uh f8
threatening to to
take and the question is what should
white do now still you've got E4 hanging
so probably you need to move the queen
so let's say you move Queen
A2 then uh I can play this tricky
move white cannot take I mean he can
take but uh
this leads to a distinct Advantage for
black if you cannot take what exactly do
you play also to protect your E4 Pawn
it's uh it's really really a problem so
maybe this was a good Bishop f8 but uh
this is a really computer move what uh
High Krishna played I think was was
really fine it led to led to uh a good
position for black all the way but um
let oh
sorry Queen A6 he just improved his
piece
position introducing those ideas and
pushing the pawn black is better and he
he's better all the way but at the end
um you see that it's hard to make any
progress so
um he probably had some improvement
along the way but I'm not sure at which
point Queen got
exchanged Bishop to
B5 yeah the a pawn is
dangerous all this looks perfectly
logical he's um approved the
bishop this is a move now in the
position
yeah it's certainly good for black but
is it winning a couple of moves
later
check around here you're starting to ask
yourself how exactly are you going to
make any progress with white just uh
sits and
waits in the game
check
we see that white has repositioned his
Bishop on C4 and um in this uh position
he always attacks A2 and E6 and black
therefore is tied down to this pawn and
um it's probably here already a clear
draw as I don't see how black would be
able to manage to even activate his King
and this is the only way to make any
sort of progress and because you're
simply always tied down to E6 and A2 so
maybe A2 wasn't uh really the way to go
but uh still how do you how do you
um get ahead here King over it's a long
way and you cannot go to
B5 yeah need much more time to figure
out if har Krishna was was able to
to win in this game so um in the game we
had a couple of more
moves a slight change of the point
structure check
check yeah and T draw was agreed um it's
quite funny that the computer still
thinks even at the in the final position
that black has a very distinct Advantage
but uh
he um just goes around in circles in the
variation he cannot show you any kind of
progress um black is just shuffling and
uh White is also shuffling just always
Bishop back and forth and black always
shuffles around here it's just a draw I
think but um maybe someone is able to to
find something probably before black
went
A2 okay as still not uh through our
games Leo against
V Let's uh do this
also and I think this is the last game
for this
round okay and
surprisingly when really plays the
dragon I cannot remember him ever
playing this opening uh okay he played
the dragon against huan again with some
transposition I believe I know this was
the other way around when V had even
white sorry I'm confusing something yeah
I'm not sure if he ever played the
dragon but uh
okay Liu um I think always plays the
main line here with F3
the Rouser attack and now long castles
which is also I think his favorite move
Bishop C4 being the main
alternative Bishop C4 is even a bit
sharper because it prevents the D6 D5
move and long castles black is small as
forc to play D5 and after
this
um we often get the kind of position uh
rising in the game this kind of um semi-
end game um white can grab a pawn here
by the
way but um it's not considered to be
very good I think Bishop E6 but I'm not
um I don't know the theory here black is
supposed to have good counter play
against the King on the white
side but the normal um way to play this
is Knight A4 it's also more logical than
grabbing cost you control
C5 let's
um continue for a couple of moves white
occupies this nice post on
C5 KN
F4 and uh Queen to E3 yeah this is a
fairly typical position for the line
with long castles and D5 where white um
enjoys a slight very slight edge with a
little play for black this is really one
of the lines that um is a bit of a
problem for for the dragon player at
least psychologically because you're
simply defending a slightly worse
position and you don't have the usual
interesting um technically Rich
positions um not exactly this position I
mean this is just one uh possibility but
this kind of uh relatively dry position
isn't very uh attractive for black to
play um of course he's got Alternatives
he can play E5 for example in this
position okay but back to the game Queen
E3 Knight
F4 and Knight to D5 so a good regrouping
the Knight went to
D5 and D6 yeah and I looked um at the
game at about this point and I was
really rather confident that
um this should end in a draw actually
because I thought uh on a very abstract
level well how is white going to make
any progress against this great knight
on
D5 the only way looks like is um at some
point to play C4 and C4 is really such a
terribly terrible looking move like
killing your Bishop um it needs to be u
under very very special circumstances
that C4 is a good move and how do you
make progress in fact I thought the only
way would be with Queen off to to get a
rook to C5 and this happened in the game
okay let's see what
happens okay black um threatened A4 so
white needed to prevent it and
um Queen's off and now White tries
exactly what I was just uh
um saying getting a rook to C5 to attack
the
pawn and this
Pawn so we can just Advance a couple of
moves yeah some strengthening moves on
both sides and still it looks very
difficult for um for white to make any
real
progress as long as this Knight is
keeping the position together in fact
the only way is uh to Simply take it at
some point and this is what Leo did a
couple of moves later he did the utmost
in preparation and
uh then took
it waiting to move 31 accidentally 41
when you have more time time on the
clock takes and C4 this was the idea um
pressurizing
D5 and black needed to
take so um okay how to assess this
position of course white is better
there's no doubt about that but um
should black be able to hold
it probably yes it's not much fun but um
it's
um it should be possible White's
Advantage is
um because um of his better Rook
Mobility The Rook is attacking A5 this
can be increased this pressure and he's
got um the potentially better King
supporting um a later maybe coming pass
Pawn on the queen
side it's not it's not great for black
but uh he's got defensive uh resources
of course in the game um in fact um van
villy was very had some ways to improve
but um yeah let's see what uh
what yeah Rook B5 of course cannot
exchange now this would be um grave
mistake giving white the decisive pass
Pawn so black just
stays we've got um those typical
improving moves yeah F6 takes away those
squares but weakens the
pawns not so sure about this move but uh
okay there are clear improvements later
but black is in a position of of
suffering all the time this is clear but
um he could I think defend much better
Rook G8 check to
G6 Rook B6 yeah attacking the B Pawn now
white uh grabed on
G6 takes takes yeah and here I think
black simply um needed to take on
G3 I think he very much likely could
have defended better before yeah but um
Maybe This was um was the last chance
but it's already already critical um
yeah I think Rook takes
G3 for example Rook takes uh E6 Rook to
A3 um King F5 hook takes King G5 King
D7 something like this it's um it's
probably lost
also yeah the F
Pawn Yeah in my notes I had this as a
possible Improvement but now looking at
this what is black doing against the F
Pawn it's maybe already too late yeah
it's already maybe too late
F6 not sure about this move it's it's
really
weakening and I don't see really what
white was
threatening okay yeah well in the
game we had the king to
D7 and white is um simply mopping up the
pawns and has got two extra pawns now
and um those
two flank pawns are are too dangerous
and white can
also easily coordinate now with the Rook
to
G5 this is nicely protected it stops any
kinds of pawn moves it protects A5 and
of course the H Pawn is free to go check
check yeah here it
is just covering the square
check and again the H Pawn can
move look at
H1 and now we see the point of all this
now the a
pawn is the
deciding factor with white having The
Rook behind the pass Pawn which is of
course the ideal
scenario and um here black resigned it's
simply that black has no way to prevent
uh The
Invasion
kingra Rook a six it doesn't matter
really black can can only sit and
wait with the Rook behind the pass Pawn
you can never move the rook and white
will simply uh grab the pawn at some
point it's also
um not helping if black
um does something like
this
you just need to be be patient in your
in your
Maneuvers at some point you will get
this with check or with the king so it's
it's completely completely lost with the
Rook behind the a pawn okay um a
technical win at the end for for Leo and
um probably around here um there needs
to be some improvement for for black to
to save this game but I didn't uh have
the time um to to look uh to look deeply
into this and this video already
is has Got U Motion Picture length 96
Minutes um unbelievable all right so I
hope you enjoyed it if you're still
awake after 90 minutes and um I'll be
back also of course on Saturday and
Sunday to um give you the games of the
last um two rounds all all right till
then
bye